hi
guys welcome to the film independent
spirit awards
i'm melissa villa senor as you may have
noticed
we are not in the big tent on the beach
instead
we're in a place more familiar to
independent film fans
a completely empty theater
well to be fair it's not a completely
empty theater
if you hear laughing it's just a
production crew they're watching
caddyshack
this was a tough year to get people to
watch independent movies
who spends all day reading covet
statistics
and then it's like um i could really go
for a long slow film with an ambiguous
ending right now
tonight we celebrate the directors
writers and actors
who embody the spirit of independent
film all in hopes of one day getting to
make a marvel movie
for the first time the spirit awards has
added categories for television
because if there's one note award shows
keep getting is
make the show longer
and of course tonight we'll be honoring
the best movies you heard
were really good there's manari which
has the funniest movie grandma not
played by tyler perry
sound of metal is a film about a heavy
metal drummer who starts losing his
hearing on tour
can you imagine a metal band where the
drummer can't even hear what he's
playing
it would sound like every metal band
sorry about that one so much sound of
metal is up for three awards tonight
or for any heavy metal drummers watching
sound of medals up for three awards
one night in miami will receive the
robert altman award
which honors films where people talk
over one another
that's a smart joke about altman's
extensive use of overlapping dialogue
and if you didn't get it why are you
even watching this art house awards show
you poser
one night in miami is also winning the
award for
best film that sounds like porn but
isn't
better luck next time rainey's black
bottom
ma rainey's black bottom made me feel
seen because
i am also an underappreciated diva who
will stop the show right now
if someone doesn't bring me a goddamn
soda
i don't want it anymore get away go
and i gotta say no mad land really
changed the way i look at people who
drive around alone and beat up white
vans
i used to think oh there goes a sex
offender
but now i think there goes a nice lady
navigating grief and economic
uncertainty
i love independent movies because they
can be wildly inventive and tend to stay
away from the typical mainstream fair
like the assistant it's a movie about a
woman who works for an abusive hollywood
mogul
i mean where do they come up with this
stuff so imaginative
promising a woman is an important movie
about a woman who pretends to get drunk
so she can catch men being jerks i'm not
sure she needed to do the whole pretend
to be drunk part
she could have just made a joke on
twitter
there are very few white men nominated
tonight
in fact two of our biggest awards best
male lead and best director have no
white male nominees at all
in other words if there was an after
party the dance floor would be poppin
that's how i dance it's not good
it seems the only movies white men made
this year were the ones they posted to
their social media on january 6.
tonight we're showcasing films that
expose racism
sexism ageism rape culture abortion
the immigrant experience ableism
financial insecurity
the prison industrial complex and
healthcare corruption
now who's ready to have a good time
let's do this